one ace up my gamers ha
what's up everyone I'm inside a gamer
game my name is Pippa and let's play
some frickin video games some of you
guys have the audacity to say that I'm
not a gamer enough
I don't play enough games from this
channel oh yeah well what is this then
I went inside a video game I am a video
game now stop distracting me I'm playing
video games now this game is actually
really cool yeah so there's a ton of
mods that I've been sold like you can
use Logan port knife and fork neo
katanas plasmas whoa epic neo katana and
let's just start off with a nice simple
song here we go dude how am I so bad oh
I'm waiting them wrong
why do you know what time
[Music]
oh ha ha ha gamer gamer gamer aah gasps
gasps
[Music]
Wow oh my god one hand bro
okay okay stop stop sorry oh it's tough
being a gamer no one told me it was this
much work yeah okay I have something
that I've been wanting to do for a long
time we're gonna pick the Minecraft and
then we're gonna play the minecraft song
okay this is gonna hit the hay apiece
we're just gonna mine
[Music]
I'm gonna guess I'm not a miner after
all just got a mine really fast that's
all I gotta do is I got our mind really
fast
[Music]
I was born with a pickaxe I was bred by
the pickaxe I am the pickaxe this is how
minecraft was meant to be played this is
how notch wanted it all along I knew
wait this is the real mining experience
and there's no goddamn creeper alright
let's play an actual one yeah oh yeah oh
oh oh my god that looks insane just this
once
Bob oh my maybe not that saber maybe not
let's pick something more reasonable
look gray I missed the last ones I just
heard a noise and I'm like what is
happening
Wow I got a me heck off thanks game
alright what are the Sabres did we got
okay that's pretty cool
dinnertime it's lunch day look at this H
lasagna time boys does it look as
ridiculous as it feels
[Music]
Mike oh my god okay yeah I can't do that
wait okay this should be epic here we go
oh yes
[Music]
Oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
don't send this to box whatever YouTube
okay manses playing video games
[Music]
this beauty pie grunting huh
it keeps going
[Music]
how help again that's what I'm talking
about
thanks to what I'm saying oh heck yes
bro that was epic that was a real gamer
moment if you thought that was a real
game room moment you make sure to leave
a like leaked hey dude okay I mean I am
early to gamer what can I say but like
okay there's one song err putt egg'
plains this song is a race and I I read
downloaded this game oh this is tight
there yeah this thing we so high
[Music]
yeah oh my god this song is amazing time
here it comes oh my god is impossible
[Music]
okay hard come on face
what are you doing wake up oh god damn
it
[Music]
Oh Oh who's a pro-gamer now huh but it
doesn't work the stupid fish stupid fish
here we go this is what I'm eating
oh I'm sorry am i slaying right now I do
think so yes okay this is an epic anime
gamer moment coming right up I feel it
[Music]
that was amazing
Showtime straight line good 10 time I'm
moving all right yes
[Music]
huh
this is the greatest moment of my life
oh you know this is such a pain in the
[ __ ] ass to set up but it's worth it
it's goddamn worth it there's a dial up
oh my god
[Music]
ah
is this it I'm scared
is it working I think this is actually
working how long does it keep go
I think I see the end
[Music]
Oh God please please stop
I see the end I see the end
[Music]
well that was epic all right Bruce that
was it for beat Sabre this time but
remember to keep smiling and having good
days and keep mining smash like on this
video and buy all the merch to prove
that you are also a gamer and I'll see
you browse next
[Music]
you want pyramids
we got them oh you're into castles huh
we got you covered baby you want some
bets easy we got it all this game is
still relevant goddamn it
you